merci pour le groupe l'est républicain
la parole et a perdu tout régime merci
madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
notre assemblée vient de débuter
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2015
la transmission des entreprises est un
sujet majeur qui mérite une attention
particulière ainsi 685000 entreprises
devraient être transmises chaque année
dans notre pays
seulement 60 mille sont mises en vente
et sur ses 60 milles seulement trente
mille d'entre elle trouvera pas preneur
il existe donc une véritable insécurité
juridique et financière qui fragilise
nos entreprises
alors qu'il conviendrait d'instaurer sur
le long terme
une montée en gamme de nos pme et
entreprises de taille intermédiaire des
amendements visant à créer
l'investisseur à long terme ont été
déposés en commission l'un d'eux a donné
lieu à un vote à égalité ne permettant
pas son adoption
ces amendements seront discutés en
séance à partir de cet après midi un
moment où l'investissement est à l'arrêt
la création de ce statut d'investisseur
de long terme peu coûteux pour les
finances publique constituerait un
signal fort de confiance en direction
des investisseurs qui prennent des
risques pour développer les entreprises
de taille intermédiaire monsieur le
premier ministre il est plus que temps
de recréer dans notre pré pays
un environnement favorable à
l'entreprise de redonner l'envié
d'investir avec un système fiscal
incitatif et non dissuasif l'entreprise
étant par ailleurs créatrice d'emplois
dans cette période où les chiffres du
chômage atteigne des sommets
une telle mesure serait plus
qu'opportune même si le plfr prévoit de
favoriser une réorientation de l'épargné
des ménages au bénéfice du financement
des entreprises
il convient de regretter l'absence
d'initiative gouvernementale sur l'
investisseur à long terme alors que la
transmission et le développement des
entreprises offrent de vraies pistes
alors quelles mesures concrètes et
pragmatiques pouvez vous annoncer
concernant la transmission des
entreprises et ensuite allez vous enfin
envoyer un signal fort aux chefs
d'entreprises désireux d'associer leurs
cadres et leurs salariés à
l'actionnariat ou aux jeunes entreprises
merci la parole est à m cet été a du
cachet du budget merci madame la
présidente monsieur le député madame la
députée véronique louwagie peux pas vous
laisser dire que le gouvernement aurait
été insensible au financement des pme
madame le magic qui est-ce qui a créé le
pea pme pour favoriser l'investissement
dans les petites et moyennes entreprises
qui est ce qui va mettre en conformité
avec le droit européen a fait afin de
sécuriser les investissements dans une
entreprise de dispositifs dits sfp m
qui est ce qui va se montrer favorable
un certain nombre d'amendements tout à
l'heure dans cet hémicycle pour aligner
les dispositif madelin sur les
dispositifs du fpm pardon de ce débat
technique vous attirer notre attention
sur une question très précise qui la
question des investisseurs à long terme
laissons le débat parlementaire se
développer gouvernement a montré a déjà
montré et montrera encore que la
question d'investissement dans les pme
voire l'appui pour que des pme pu se
transformer en note et y
la volonté du gouvernement et complète
il a d'ailleurs ce gouvernement et vous
ne l'aviez jamais fait mis en place un
train nombre de dispositifs
d'investissement pour déplacer les fonds
considérables qui sont placées en
assurance vie sur des fonds plus
directement lié à ce que certains
appellent l'économie réelle alors nous
ont tout à l'heure je crois à partir de
17h à reprendre ce débat sur toutes ces
questions
je rappelle aussi que la c3s a été
supprimée pour les petites entreprises
contribution qui pesé sur la trésorerie
et sur la capacité d'investissement des
entreprises
nul n'a le monopole du soutien aux pme
mais force est de constater que ce
gouvernement par l'ensemble des mesures
législatives qu'il a déjà pris et qu'il
prendra encore je pense dans la soirée
avec le parlement n'a pas de leçon à
recevoir en la matière
merci mes chers collègues je vous
rappelle